le seul moyen pour moi de garder le
spectateur avec elle et avec l'histoire
c'est en fait de lui faire ressentir ce
qu'elle ressent c'est pour ça que vous
êtes chamboule finalement le processus
est très simple une fois qu'il a accepté
scénario jeudi montus a bien vu que le
personnage était sous stéroïdes
bah du coup alors que seize chevaux et
partir de ce moment la menace en était
ravi de le faire vraiment ravis avec
vincent de partage vraiment ce truc sur
en fait la corporalité des personnages
d'autant plus que moi je dirige que sur
les corps et que lui ne veut être que
d'origine naturalisé supporte pas être
une de psychologie nation et tout ça il
m'avait expliqué une fois que pour la
loi du marché il avait vraiment étudié
comment bien prendre son taux qui en
faisant le geste 12 milliards de fois 50
cent mille fois d'affilée pour être sûr
que ça ait l'air naturel mais ça c'est
un travail déjà sur le cancer
déjà c'est se mettre dans le personnage
s'émousser se mouvoir parmi son
personnage et donc je servais sur le
proposant que kylie kick qu'il était
bonne personne pour ça et donc à partir
de vraies du moment où il acceptait le
scénario ben c'était parti pour de la
fonte tous les jours pendant un an
moi il ya toujours un petit peu de sage
dans grave s'était déjà présence moi je
veux pas m'en empêcher
et puis je pense que quand on parle de
choses aussi noir d'un univers voilà qui
est aussi pour moi le risque
apocalyptique
on a besoin de soupapes et jeudi ont
évidemment le spectateur en premier mais
moi aussi faire même moi quand j'écris
au fur et à mesure de l'écriture c'est
vraiment je vais sortir d'une scène où
c'est dense intense pour moi de
l'imaginer de l'écrire ce machin madiba
tient là il faut que je m une scène de
comédie
c'est juste que de fait en fait
naturellement la scène que je vais
écrire après elle va désamorcer tout ça
juste pour aller souffler un petit peu
et aussi un petit peu rires de
l'extravagance de mai situation parce
que c'est vrai quand on propose aussi
des choses un peu grandiloquente un peu
baroque parfois c'est vrai que c'est
c'est important d'en rire ya quand même
un recul de 6 par rapport à ça soit